was für ein Paukenschlag diese Woche aus
Karlsruhe das
Bundesverfassungsgericht raubt die Ampel
aus schickt sie arm und total blamiert
nach Hause zum ersten Mal überhaupt wird
ein Bundeshaushalt für verfassungswidrig
erklärt und eine Ampel im panikmodus
muss urplötzlich 60 Milliarden
auftreiben irgendwie ja wo sollen die
herkommen wo sollen die herkommen das
weiß keiner was wir wissen nicht
genutzte coronamilliarden dürfen also
doch nicht in den Klima und
transformationsfond überführt werden
kreative Buchführung ist scheinbar
verboten und die Regierung hat keinen
Plan B man ist wirklich geschockt und
überrascht von der Klatsche aus
Karlsruhe das ist nicht nur eine
Klatsche das ist sogar eine
riesenklatsche ein bitterer Rückschlag
eine Klatsche mit Wums große peinliche
Nummer nicht zu sagen mit doppelwums
feige
riesenklatsche ja das ist natürlich eine
absolute Schlappe für die
Ampelkoalition muss man sagen dieses
Urteil also finde ich zu hart
muss ich sagen sag wir mal Schlamperei
denn Experten Leute die sich auskennen
hatten von Anfang an vor dem Corona
Enkeltrick gewarnt 2021 erdacht vom
großen Finanzexperten Olaf Scholz
umgesetzt vom König der
Schattenhaushalte Christian Lindner ja
ja umso
lustiger umso ulkiger dass seine FDP
sich jetzt hinstellt und sagt sehr gutes
Urteil es stärkt die Schuldenbremse die
ihr und Lindner austrixen wolltet wie
frech kann man sein Gut wo wird denn
jetzt der Rotstift angesetzt gibt's da
schon erste Ideen bis in die frühen
Morgenstunden hat der Haushaltsausschuss
des Bundestags getagt jetzt gibt es
erste Ergebnisse gekürzt werden soll
etwa beim Elterngeld aber auch das
Schnitzel im Restaurant wird wohl bald
teurer so jetzt
reicht's seid ihr bescheuert meine
Elterngeld von mir aus aber wer kürzt
denn beim Schnitzel tja jetzt müssen sie
halt zum ersten Mal überhaupt
Prioritäten setzen die ampelmusen denn
irgendwie muss das fehlende Geld
natürlich am Ende reinkommen irgendwo
muss es herkommen es geht nicht
anders crazy Vorschlag crazy Vorschlag
meinerseits jeder opfert jetzt mal was
von den drei Partnern die FDP verzichtet
z.B auf Dienstwagen Privileg und
dieselsubvention dafür überlegen sich
die Grünen eine neue Klimapolitik statt
Verfallsdaten für Heizungen die man dann
wieder mit teuren Subventionen
ausgleichen muss einfach CO2 Preis hoch
und klimageld an die Bürger auszahlen
fertig damit diese Regierung vielleicht
mal wieder ernst genommen wird hier Olaf
Scholz in seinem neuen comedypogramm zum
Urteil aus Karlsruhe das ist eine
Entscheidung die die Bundesregierung und
sicherlich auch der Haushaltsgesetzgeber
beachten wird und wo wir jetzt
genau ja ja war ein guter GCK ne fand
das selber Scholz will das Urteil
beachten wie großzügig oder die Ampel
muss ich jetzt sehr schnell auf eine
neue Politik inklusive Zumutung für alle
einigen und die dann Achtung gemeinsam
verkaufen das wird eine völlig neue
Erfahrung für die oder man fliegt
auseinander und es gibt Neuwahlen was
original keiner will außer der AFD ja
für die AFD läuft's gerade optimal
passend dazu diskutiert das Land ein
mögliches Verbot der Alternative für
Deutschland ja spiegeltitelgeschichte
diese Woche und der CDU-Mann und
exostbeauftragte Marco wanderwitz hat
sogar schon den ersten Verbotsantrag
formuliert das ist sage ich Ihnen eine
brandgefährliche Diskussion denn sie
riecht leider nach Angst nach mitten im
Spiel die Regeln ändern die AFD feiert
derweil ihre Umfragewerte und den nach
armrötung wieder topfitten Vorsitzenden
und der Arm funktioniert wieder alles in
Ordnung kriegen sie wieder
hoch bewegen also von daher bin ich
wieder voll funktionsfähig und ja Gott
sei Dank Gott sei Dank er kriegt ih
wieder hoch meine Damen und Herren ja
toll die AFD SachsenAnhalt wurde jetzt
offiziell als gesichert rechtsextrem
eingestuft was ihre Anhänger gesichert
nicht interessiert für ein Parteiverbot
sind die Hürden bei uns zurecht sehr
hoch man müsste z.B nachweisen dass die
planvoll daran arbeiten die
demokratische Grundordnung zu beseitigen
abgesehen davon würden die
entsprechenden Ansichten ja mit einem
Verbot nicht verschwinden und wissen Sie
was noch gegen ein AFD Verbot spricht
die ganzen AFD Parlamentarier säßen dann
nur noch bei sich zu Hause und das kann
man den Armen Ehepartnern wirklich nicht
antun typisch staatsfunkt ich mE guck
dir den Land doch an der Lutscher ist ja
noch nicht mal deutscher alles Teil des
großen Plans der Globalisten eine
umfolkung was denn sonst die wollen uns
austauschen oh the great Reset und
George Soros der zieht wie immer an den
Fäden ja ich bete dass Putin hier bald
einmarschiert und diesen grünen spuck
ein Ende
macht bist du so lieb und holst mir noch
ein Bier wo war ich ach ja l genau
eindeutigch ein
echenmensch
verbieten
glaube überhaupt keine gute Debatte
meine tatsächlich gibt es ja in
Deutschland nicht plötzlich mehr Leute
mit einem rechten Weltbild die haben
jetzt nur ein gemeinsames Sammelbecken
die AFD und die eher bürgerlichen Wähler
die holen Sie sich mit Kulturkampf diese
Leute wählen dann einen Faschisten wie
höcke damit sie nicht Gendern
müssen klingt komisch ist aber so und
man kann ja unseren Bernt hier sagen was
man will aber der sagt inzwischen
ziemlich unverblümt wohin die Reise geht
jetzt liebe Freunde ist der Ernstfall
offenkundig jetzt sind wir in das
Stadium des vorburgerkriegs eingetreten
und glaubt mir wenn es hart auf hart
kommt dann werden wir uns erkennen dann
werden wir uns finden dann sind wir das
was wir immer waren und Deutsch und eine
Gemeinschaft die die Zukunft
erkämpfen ja da fehlen wirklich nur noch
der reinische Dialekt und der
Klumpfuß Bern freut sich übrigens total
über die Verbotsdebatte denn sie hilft
ihm sich als Verteidiger der Demokratie
aufzuspielen obwohl in seinem
Deutschland Grundrechte garantiert nur
noch fürs ethnokulturell homogene
Staatsvolk gelten würden es ist ja so
wenn es richtig doof läuft muss man den
freistad Thüringen nach der Wahl
nächstes Jahr leider umbenennen in
Nationalpark
Thüringen Bernt höcke ist und bleibt der
eigentliche Strippenzieher der AFD und
das Idol der Partei Jugend hier
belästigt von SpiegelTV warum sind Sie
bei der jungen Alternativen es g keine
Inter der jung
Alter also eigentlich wurde das meapfon
erfunden damit man nicht mehr brüllen
muss aber egal ist egal mein Vorschlag
Schluss mit der Verbotsdebatte und
lieber nach Polen gucken Donald Tusk
macht doch vor wie es geht statt sie auf
Schlammschlachten mit solchen Leuten
einzulassen mit einer positiven Vision
dagegen halten sagen wofür man ist ja
damit hat er gewonnen in einem Land in
dem die Rechtspopulisten schon alle
relevanten Medien kontrollieren weil die
Menschen da gemerkt haben dass z.B
Fremdenfeindlichkeit zwangsläufig zu
noch mehr Fachkräftemangel führt wä in
Deutschland exakt dasselbe da müssen sie
sich die wütenden AFD meckeroppers
mangelspfleger am Ende gegenseitig die
Windel wechseln ja vom Wohlstandsverlust
nach einem dexit mal ganz zu schweigen
ich sage man muss sie argumentativ
stellen hier die Bundestagspräsidentin
macht's vor nicht nur dass diese
Politiker dafür sorgen dass sie liebe
Frauen nicht mehr angstfrei durch
deutsche Städte gehen können dass jeder
perverslink in Zukunft in ihre
Schutzräume eindringen kann wenn er
einfach nur behauptet eine Frau zu sein
nicht angespr würden Sie bitte zur Sache
reden Herr Hilse das hat mit dem
energiewitschaftsrecht nichts zu
tun
PCH oh Gott ja wirklich Thema ist
Energie Wirtschaftsrecht und er labert
über transmenschen in der falschen Sauna
also solche Sorgen möchte man haben aber
nicht nur Polen macht Hoffnung meine
Damen und Herren auch Großbritannien wo
die brexitanhänger längst in der
Minderheit sind nach unzähligigen
gebrochenen Versprechungen nigel Farage
also mrter brexit geht bald und das ist
ausdrücklich kein Witz ins Englische
Dschungelcamp ja was für eine Demütigung
was für eine wunderbare
Vision so ber du frisst heute
krokodilpenis püe und zwar aus dem
Bioladen absolut würdelos ich werde das
dem Führer
melden ich bin Faschist Holt mich hier
raus ja man wird do noch treumen dürfen
oder
ja ich sag mal so ganz ehrlich ich war
nie so richtig Fan von dem Format aber
dann würde ich es gucken in jedem Fall
so die Debatte um ein mögliches
afdverbot reden wir drüber mit Gisa
Flake vom Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz Abteilung
Rechtsextremismus Frau flakee sie
beobachten AFD landesverbände aber hallo
ich beobachte die von morgens bis abends
ich beobachte mir quasi ein Wolf man
fragt sich nur warum ist die AFD
rechtsextrem ja natürlich was denn sonst
ist es nachts auf dunkel scheiß der Bär
in Wald möchte man nie wieder in seinem
Leben einen Artikel über die Pochers
lesen ja ja und ja fürs offensichtliche
brauche ich keinen Geheimdienst und die
AFD TAH sich ja nicht mal mehr weil sie
es nicht muss hier Beispiel Siegbert
Dröse er heißt wirklich so AFD Kandidat
für die Europawahl hatte 2016 in seinem
Fuhrpark ein Auto mit ah
1818 bekannter nazicode heißt übersetzt
so viel wie Adolf Hitler Adolf Hitler
Adolf
Hitler aha steht für Adolf Hitler und
ich dachte der W Riesenfan von Anton
Hofreiter welke sie brauchen dringend
Hilfe und das sind nicht mal alle
Indizien im Fall Dröse
hier posiert er mit der Hand auf dem
Herz vor Hitlers Führerbunker die AFD
hat ihn trotzdem zu einem
aussichtsreichen Kandidaten für das
Europaparlament nominiert na sichi beim
Parteitag im Sommer mit
79,2% gewählt zieht wohl sicher ins
Europaparlament ein in anderen Ländern
müssen sich rechtsextreme bürgerlich
tanen in Deutschland nicht keine Ahnung
warum vielleicht haben wir doch was in
der a oder im Trinkwasser ich weiß es
doch auch nicht aber ab 5:45 Uhr wird
zurück beobachtchuldigung
chuldigung
sie sie wirken irgendwie desillusioniert
kann das sein ach sag bloß Bernt höcke
die man laut Gerichtsurteil offiziell
Faschist nennen muss könnte nächstes
Jahr Ministerpräsident von Thüringen
werden gut Thüringen ist jetzt eher ein
Wald als Bundesland aber trotzdem höcke
freut sich in seinem Buch bald ein neues
Kapitel unserer Geschichte aufschlagen
zu können Zitat auch wenn wir leider ein
paar Volksteile verlieren werden die zu
schwach oder nicht willend sind sich der
fortschreitenden afrikanisierung
orientalisierung und Islamisierung zu
widersetzen also ich verliere manchmal
meine Autoschlüssel aber wie verliert
man denn Volksteile ja die sind dann
halt
Weg zur Kur woanders an einem besseren
Ort Sibirien m gibt sich dann und genau
dieser Mann steht mit der AFD Thüring
zumindest laut einer Umfrage bei
34% bei 40 hätte er schon die absolute
Mehrheit dann kann er in Thüringen
mindestens Richter auf Lebenszeit
bestimmen
oder den örtlichen Verfassungsschutz
kontrollieren
der alte Traum Faschisten kontrollieren
sich
selbst ist ja das ist ja alles furchtbar
ja es sei denn dieser Staat lässt sich
überraschen doch noch Eier wachsen aber
damit rechne ich nicht mehr deswegen
habe ich auch gekündigt und arbeite ab
sofort für den Verfassungsschutz der
kommenden machabe der nennt sich
BND ist eine Abkürzung für Berns
Nachricht
meine Aufgabe ist das Überwachen von
Moderatoren der feindlichen
systemmedien/
rundfunkhuren und wen beobachten Sie das
so kann ich ihn leider nicht sagen das
ist geheim ah ja machen Sie einfach
weiter als wäre ich gar nicht
da okay mache ich Geser
flacke so me her
und dann ist heute Abend natürlich noch
Date night in Berlin Olaf Scholz
empfängt den türkischen Präsidenten
Erdogan das wird aber nicht zu hochgängt
es ist ein Arbeitsbesuch es gibt kaum
gemeinsame Termine einfach nur dreig
Gänge Abendbrot im Kanzler am Feierabend
das ist ruckzuck
erledigt und ich sage Ihnen dieser Gast
hier beschert der Ampel ein echtes
Dilemma denn erdo ist natopartner und
zumindest ein möglicher Vermittler im
nost Konflikt kleiner Haken zum
Vermitteln müsste man irgendwie neutral
sein und das ist offensichtlich nicht so
sein
Ding die Hamas ist keine terroristische
Organisation sie ist eine
befreiungsgruppe die kämpft um ihre
Leute und ihr Land zu schützen ach guck
mal das wusste ich gar nicht dass
Erdogan auch bei Fridays for future
mitmacht schöne Grüße an Greta Thunberg
es ist schlimm es ist wirklich schlimm
auf der anderen Seite der Mann
kontrolliert halt immer noch eine
wichtige flüchtlingsroute die Ampel
braucht ihn also und exakt so tritt er
natürlich auch auf weil er das weiß und
es hilft
nichts es hilft ja nichts ja müssen wir
bei manchen Erdogan reden mal weghören
ich sag mal solange nicht behauptet die
Israelis wärden
Faschisten diejenigen die mit Gewalt das
Land an sich gerissen haben auf dem die
Palästinenser seit tausenden Jahren
gelebt haben versuchen einen Staat
aufzubauen der erst seit 75 Jahren
besteht und dessen Legitimität durch
ihren eigenen Faschismus fragwürdig
geworden
ist ja aber hey das sollten sich die
Israelis jetzt nicht zu sehr zu Herz
nehmen erogan hat das schon über alle
möglichen Leute gesagt W der schon alles
als Faschisten bezeichnet hat 2017 sogar
mal und es kein Witz die Holländer
wirklich die
Holländer und Diplomatie sie sind nervös
und feige sie sind Nachkommen der Nazis
sie sind
Faschisten ja leider völlig
richtig leider völlig richtig wie dieses
Foto von Rü Hitler und seiner Frau
anchebraun beweist meine Damen und
Herren und trotzdem trotz allem müssen
wir mit Erdogan reden alles andere wä
naiv wenn der Boss vom bossbus den
eutürkei Deal komplett aufkündigt dann
haben wir ein Problem kurz gesagt
Arbeitsbesuch muss sein muss sein nur
dann halt diskret das heißt ohne großen
medienbahnhof und wenn einer unbedingt
Fotos machen will an so einem Tag wie
heute dann gibt's ja Tricks ne Olaf
Scholz z.B arbeitet zur Tarnung heute
mit zwei Augenklappen und der
Bundespräsident hat sich extra für erdo
eine neue Brille gekauft
clever cleverer move natürlich sind wir
in gewisser Weise erpress aber ich sag
mal so das ist ja keine Einbahnstraße
wir haben auch Erpressungspotenzial
Erdogan braucht eine liberalere
visavgabe er braucht die Europäische
Union und ihren Binnenmarkt da liegen
unsere Hebel oder noch ein Gedanke e
erdo bisher kommen hauptsächlich unsere
gepflegten Touristen in die Türkei hier
solche gediegenen Besserverdiener das
muss aber nicht so bleiben erdo
vielleicht machen wir demnächst mal die
sogenannte malallerout dicht und dann
kommen alle Mallorca Asis aus diesem
Billigflieger zu dir nach Antal ja
überlegst dir wir können auch anders
ero wir können auch anders wir sagen
mehr Selbstbewusstsein von unserer Seite
ist gefragt Beispiel warum sind die
Grauen Wölfe diese rechtsextremen
Hardcore erdo Fans in Deutschland immer
noch nicht verboten nennt sie fäer prüft
das wohl noch heißt es toll ja seit seit
2020 wird das schon vom Innenministerium
geprüft in Deutschland leben erdoan
Gegner in in ständiger Angst oder sogar
unter Polizeischutz warum nehmen wir das
hin oder dass der islamverband ditip
eindeutig Erdogans verlängerte Arm in
Deutschland ist und in mehreren
Bundesländern Einfluss hat auf den
islamischen Religionsunterricht an
deutschen
Schulen die ditip die ditip ist direkt
der türkischen Religionsbehörde dianet
unterstellt deren Chef Ali erbasch
Israel als Zitat rostigen Dolch im
Herzen der islamischen geographie
bezeichnet das zionistische Israel
begeht in Gaza einen Völkermord mit
seinen Angriffen die auf einem
schmutzigen und perversen Glauben
basieren bei der Sendung mit der Maus
würde man jetzt sagen das war
antisemitisch gleichzeitig müssen wir
natürlich höllisch aufpassen dass sich
hier in Deutschland kein Antisemitismus
Generalverdacht gegen Muslime breit
macht auch dazu gibt's aktuell leider
eine klare Tendenz zu den Fakten die
ditip ist Kooperationspartner für den
islamischen Religionsunterricht in
nordrin-westfalen Niedersachsen und
Hessen auch da wird der Lehrplan von
Islamwissenschaftlern an Unis erarbeitet
trotzdem haben die Islamverbände
tatsächlich Einfluss auf den
Unterrichtsstoff in Hessen sind das
ahmadia und tatsächlich die die und wir
schalten mal live zu Matthias Matschke
Rektor an der evelyine bordecki
Grundschule in Frankfurt
Bockenheim Herr matke sie planen gerade
mit einem katholischen und einem
islamischen Lehrer das nächste Halbjahr
fehlt da nicht die evangelische Kirche
ja Herr Welge die evangelische Kollegin
lässt sich entschuldigen die hat sich
heute im eigenen Unterricht so
gelangweil da hat jetzt ein Burnout ja
aber zurück zu dietip ja mit denen
wollte hen ja gar nicht mehr
zusammenarbeiten hat aber dabei
vergessen den Vertrag ordnungsgemäß zu
kündigen h das kennt man ja vom skyabo
ne so und mal die Tip hin und her wissen
Sie was mich wirklich ärgert warum ist
Religion überhaupt einfach an der
Grundschule weiß ich auch nicht ja
setzen se Oliver Welge die
fleischgeordene bildungsmisäre wegen
Verfassung natürlich ausgerechnet
Religion ist als einziges Fach im
deutschen Grundgesetz verangert warum
kein Wort über Mathe oder wenigstens
textiles gestalten aber relit steht drin
ne in dem angeblich weltlichen Land ja
geht's noch das hat ja wohl den
stärksten Bischof vom Ministranten
ja okay aber was was ist denn jetzt ihre
Forderung ja Abschaffen des Fach Ende
Schule ist ein Ort des Wissens nicht des
Glaubens jetzt sitze ich hier abends mit
den muslimischen und christlichen
Schamanen wegen einem Fach das man gar
nicht benoten kann hier so ja aus einer
religionsarbeit fünftes buch Mose ja ter
zeugte Abraham nah und naran Haran aber
STB vor seinem Vater Terach Frage wer
zeugte Kevin und wo ist die Arche mit
den Leuten die das
interessiert gut ich meine es werden ja
im weitesten Sinne Werte vermittelt ach
hör do auf mit Werte ja so ein drittless
der hat doch schon alle Folgen von Game
of Thrones geguckt und dann komme ich
mit terr und Haran der fragt mich direkt
hier Alter wo wo sind die Drachen wo
sind die Action ja das passt doch nicht
mehr in unsere Zeit
rekordaustrittszahlen noch nie waren so
wie ig Leute in irgendeiner Kirche warum
noch religion in der Schule gut man kann
sich auch abmelden von dem Fach ja genau
und wer betreut an die kleinen ketze die
ganzen Zeit Lehrermangel schon mal
gehört aber ich weiß jetzt wie ich mich
reche wenn Protestanten Katholen und
Muslime ihren ausgedachten Fantasy Kram
verbreiten dürfen dann dürfen das bei
uns ab sofort alle Sekten ich begrüße
neu im Kollegium diesen Herrn von der
lichchen Scientology Kirche einen ganz
sympathischen Satanisten der opfert dann
mit den Kindern Katzen und so
heilsatan und den Erzbischof der
sogenannten Zeugen
Borussias die glauben ganz fest dass
Dortmund immer noch Meister werden kann
alle schwachsind bis auf das mit
Dortmund Matthias matke vielen
Dank hallo Leute ich bin der heute sch
memeersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und
mes wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
Kanal was zur Hölle ist ein
mhersteller